I want to
spend some time on what I think
most people would agree
is your biggest head,
and that is as the voice
of Elsa and Frozen.
And here you are singing.
Let it go.
How many cars
ready to
set it down to
know
what
to say
at the start rate John?
Cold never bothered me.
Anyway.
Idina, when you recorded that song,
did you have any inkling
how huge it would be?
No.
I knew it was really.
It was an accomplishment.
A great get to be a Disney princess,
you know, to be
welcomed into the Disney family
and be in a musical.
I knew that that was pretty epic,
but I had no idea
it would become the phenomenon
that it did.
So I came in once and I sang it,
and then I came back another time
because they had written
another part to it,
and they had changed some of the lyrics.
And I realized that
I felt like
my voice
sounded too mature in order to
really embody this young woman
that you see in the in the movie.
And so I asked them to take it up.
I don't know why I did that,
because then when I'm in concert
all over the world,
I, I have a cold
and I just want to kill myself.
But, but I asked them,
let's take it up a half step and see,
because then it sounds a little bit
more innocent in my voice.
A little younger, I think.
And so as I was watching it just now,
I was thinking, gees, what was I?
What was I thinking there?
But I'm glad
because she sounds a little younger
and a little bit more vulnerable and,
you know, not like I'm smoking
20 cigarets before I get up.
No, I also was not smoke,
not that I smoke, but so.
So you sing
the song at the Oscars and it wins.
And of course, what
many people
remember about that night
is that John Travolta introduces you.
Please welcome the wickedly talented
one and only Adele Dazeem.
And here's the question I have.
What was your immediate reaction
when you heard that
And when did you realize what a huge gift
he had given you?
Okay.
So I had done
a lot of preparation
because I was super nervous
about that night.
And I knew
that it was going to be Meryl Streep
and Brad Pitt sitting in the front row.
I had done a bunch of meditation about,
you know, visualizing
manifesting that that night would go
well for me.
And I'd also told myself
I was just going to sing to my son
and just make it about
singing to my son Walker
and nothing else.
And so I had all this preparation going
on, and they get me out there
and they set me
and the spotlight comes on, and he says
that and I have about 8 seconds
to get my life together.
Together.
And what goes through my head
all in those 8 seconds
is, did he just screw up my name?
Oh, my God.
Why is this happening to me?
This is my dream
come true to be at the Oscars
and get over yourselves.
Stop having a pity party.
Oh, my God.
Brad Pitt is there and she,
you know, is us.
It was all in 8 seconds or so.
And then it was just like sing to walk
or sing to walk or, you know, be serious.
So and then, yes, I came off stage and
and then I realized that
what a great gift it would be
because I had all these followers
and sort of the Broadway world
and people that were saying,
how could he screw up her name?
But then there were all these people
that didn't know me
from other demographics and walks of life
that maybe hadn't
been to the theater
and don't know that side who said,
who is this girl? They're talking about?
So then I
you know, it
actually
widened my audience
and ended up being a great thing.
And now it's fun to just laugh about
and have you ever messed up
somebody's name that badly?
Yeah, but not at the Oscars
and maybe not quite that badly.
All right.
Here's
here's where this interview
is about to get a little weird I want
I want to spend some time talking about
let it go because I don't get it.
And and here here's
looking at me like, oh, my gosh,
I didn't get it when I saw the movie.
I didn't get it
when every one of my grandchildren
were singing the darn song.
I mean, it's a great song,
but it's
supposed to be about women
or a girl's empowerment.
But in fact,
it's about a girl
who is so messed up with her curse.
That she decides to give in duet.
And, you know,
as the line goes, let the storm rage on.
And in fact,
I even preparing for this interview,
I even read an interview
with the songwriters
who said
when they wrote that song,
they didn't know whether you, Elsa,
was a villain. Or a hero.
So.
Well, so what?
All right. I'm going deep here.
That's a lot of things
and some things
that I've thought about before.
Okay.
So why do you think it's
not a song of empowerment?
Let the storm rage on.
She's she's been holding these
all of her power.
She has to hold it back
just to wear these gloves.
Because if she really
allows herself to be herself
and to unleash this power,
she might hurt people in her life.
She's already hurt her sister.
So she's been
holding on to it
and keeping it and concealing
and keeping it inside.
And so it to me, it's about,
you know, especially as women
letting our embracing
that thing
that makes us so powerful,
that makes perhaps even ferocious
that that makes us extraordinary
in the world
and not being afraid to
share that and and be ourselves.
I promise to let it go go after this.
But she locked herself in an ice castle.
Why is that a good thing?
I love that
you're telling me the plot
in this interview.
Okay.
So, yes, she
she locks herself in her ice palace
because she feels like an outsider.
She's she's
she's been ostracized.
No one loves her. She's alone.
So she locked herself in this ice castle
you're right.
I'm I'm I'm faltering here.
I think she's just one of those
lonely people at the top.